okay I am back and this is not a live
stream this is just a recording for
YouTube so shout out to the the YouTube
audience I'm gonna do some puzzle rush
if you don't know what puzzle rush is
you're probably living under a rock but
for the few people who are watching that
don't know what it is essentially the
the goal is to solve as many puzzles as
possible in less than five minutes if I
get three correct or three incorrect
strikes then it just ends and the
puzzles get harder as I go on and this
is kind of the new craze on chess calm
and there's been a lot of GM's doing it
recently Hikaru Nakamura I think has
been the most dominant in it if we take
a look at the global leader board and
check out the all-time scores I got
excited at first because I saw my name
on top but I'm 400 17th all-time my my
personal record is 42 42 points or
whatever basically 40 to correct
problems in less than five minutes
Nakamura holds a record of 55 followed
by Andrew tang followed by jmb don't
know who this person is but there's some
there's some notable names on the list
MVL is lion beast narrowed its key
onigiri number 12 at 50 so I would like
to pass giri but it's gonna take some
work so let's start I don't know how
many of these I'm gonna do this could be
a long video
if I get addicted and can't stop myself
but we'll see how it goes
okay free queen and yeah it's gonna
start out easy couple free Queens that's
made in one that's made in one this is
made in one lots of mates in one tree
bishop free rook this should lead to
mate somehow queen h3 is mates that's
free material assume we just take on c6
and then g6 can't be defended this is
winning a bishop this is mating this is
mating this is winning a knight probably
as I go on there's gonna be less
commentary because it will get harder
this mate should be made somehow queen
g6
mmm this is gonna be mate okay 16 in a
row this is gotta work right where's the
meets there's a mates
I can take the night and then when the
bishop whoa which way are the plans
going so this Bishop is doing stuff push
there push yeah there we go a free rook
but nothing in life is free this is made
okay this is a fork
this is mate this is probably winning
material somehow okay check our bishop
maybe bishop D for Queen e1
okay I can take and Bishop b5 or just
take that lightly rook check in Queen f7
hmm this is winning the pawn this is
winning a rook right free rook mmm the
Knights attacked so Queen d6 only move
okay rook d1 your rook d1 then rook D -
ooh okay - go back and look at that one
free bishop
okay so queen of sevens of threats
so Brooke h7 huh it's weird
you have to defend somehow probably rook
h7 up a some material check and then
mate
hmm maybe this and then this hey 31 my
castle the knight is pinned
check here and g7
this is made in two
night thief oh I can win something right
take I want to win something not seeing
it though
taking on Yeats no take there maybe I
take and rook d1 no I already got two
wrong maybe night off three Chuck gets
hard 9 f3 or queen takes g4 let's go for
a night f3 okay I felt like I was on a
roll there and then things got tough
so I've I've shown a few students this
and I've told my students that it's okay
to do puzzle rush as long as you check
the puzzles that you you did on
incorrectly so let's go back let's try
and solve the ones that I missed what
was this one Oh Queen off five so this
is where I played rook d1 but maybe it
didn't lead to anything because after
Keaney - I wanted to play or rook d1
King G - D - but maybe just King f1 or
something
so it's probably queen d1 wait why can't
I move I'm so confused
ah okay now I can move Queen d1 kingi to
rook d2 King h3 Queen h5 is mate okay so
that's fine oh that messed up the
framing let me uh how did I do this I
just expand up there we go
is that better there's no one in the
stream chat to tell me if this looks
okay
hopefully that's okay don't want it to
be cut too near the edge okay let's move
on to this one ah yeah this is a
difficult one
rook d7 and I assumed white should win
material this white is currently up upon
I wanted to do something like 95 the
Knights on c7 let me try this as just as
a normal puzzle
I mean the Kings also intimating nets
when it comes to these positions it's
usually a matter of either mating or
winning material there's a lot of like
loose targets maybe rook h8 attacking
the bishop we're taking the bishop well
I I think I took the rook I wanted to
take wait what
I i right-clicked but it made the move
I thought right-clicking draws arrow let
me retry that did that really Wow
I didn't know right clicking makes a
move so I can't draw or highlight
anything so I wanted to take taking rook
d1 but I guess just like e7 or something
so
rook takes rook takes h7
not seeing anything so Brooke h8 Bishop
f7 stumped
I mean if I wanted to get this one right
it would have probably taken the
remainder of the time and maybe I still
wouldn't get it
I want people if I upload this to
YouTube I want people to comment below
if you if you've already solved it or if
you're you're stumped like me because
I'm so I'm just so perplexed here like
rook rook h8 oh we it's made into aa
just a blind spot rookie six rookie six
and then that ninety five meets forcing
moves they're important okay
so focused on trying to win material ok
one more problem
let's do this
this is where I kind of just guessed
like there's a lot of puzzles where you
just kind of you have a feeling but okay
my feeling was incorrect with Knight f3
so it's probably Queen takes g4 I mean
black is down at rook here so it's
necessary to achieve some sort of mating
attack so Queen takes g4 King f1 Queen
h3
kingi one we fork looks good
if Queen takes g14 h1 there's queen h3
King G one Knight f3 mates
okay
okay so feels like some redemption after
okay getting a position wrong and then
going back and getting it correct so
let's go back
I got 34 there let's try and beat 34
play again okay it's gonna start easy
lots of mates so far
okay
that's a fork
mmm this has got to be right right it's
a fork
hmm can take on f2
maybe g2g to Queen age - let's do it
okay it's made then - it's made into
this is me into lots of mates into this
is made in three that's a chopping
bishop
this is probably just taking a free pawn
and then threatening rookie one it's
made in one want to take on h3 and then
like d3 or e3 check and then mates okay
taken win the Knights dropping the Queen
free rook
Queen a4 or not for
or is it maybe it's queen out for a
night g3
yeah and just take the rook it's made
into oh let's check let's play c6 it's
good thing Queen g5 was illegal there
that's made in 100k so that's also
illegal let's just take the Bishop
Knight
okay let's made into okay so the Queen's
hanging the art Queens hanging juice the
queen of five free rook is it free
that's kind of okay he takes and then
King Dietz you my chief three is mates
its Queenie six and then when the Queen
okay some discovery but the Queen's
attack so rook f6 Windsor rook
maybe rook t8 or rock a5 traps of Queen
take see - mmm that's scary though
and what else to do Oh free rook
okay there's some tactic with the pin
it's confusing position though I want to
play like rook h1
murk h1 is probably working no hmm
three nights go take with Queen o h3 is
hanging so probably take with queen
it's me oh wait why was that not working
Oh is there a bishop on that feet oops
we need take the bishop 27 I've already
missed to take the bishop the checks are
scary d7 maybe not h5 so simple these
blind spots
probably Bishop d2
could taken Bishop g5
I just want to meet on f7 it's probably
working and then take here 23 seconds
left I have five
yeah running out of time no okay well I
got 40 that's two away from my personal
record two seconds left use up almost
the full time that's one thing which
I've realized which it can pay off to I
kind of take things slowly because you
were more valuable to take 30 seconds to
get the right solution rather than miss
a problem anyway let's go back let's
take a look at the ones I missed ah this
one I thought rook each one was strong
but now I'm realizing there were
discoveries with the Knights so that
probably just did not work at all so
that's in trouble here it probably
requires some sort of like defensive
mechanism let me shift this over here
there we go
so what to do
could take the rook
probably not good
hmm
it's a strange position because white
has like all these checks and there's
nowhere clear for the King to go I'd
like to just neutralize it's like Queen
h4
I could try and take the rook maybe it
just taking the rook 95 King g7 Queen e7
King c6 like before King b6
I'm really not sure I feel like black
might be able to weather the storm there
we go
and then King d7 king f7 gets meted so I
have to run this way thinking c6 miskeen
c7 also gets me that Queen takes c6 and
Queen e8 ideas
yeah interesting problem some of these
are just a matter of defending like when
material and survive let's move back to
next one I think this one was just a
dumb sort of Miss on my part because I
played Queen b6 forgetting about the
bishop yeah it's just rook d7 right rook
d7 wait riff d7 King b8 and then you're
up T
okay and then the final one I had no
time for I tried what I thought was the
most logical move I'll get it's getting
cut off here I don't know why that's
happening huh sorry if it was cut off
before it to know if it's because I have
too many tabs hmm let's just make it
smaller there we go so King g2o Queen h3
is made made into okay all right let's
try one more let me close out some tabs
and reframe everything yeah I don't know
why I have to keep reframing because the
boards are inconsistent across the pages
okay let's try and be 40 won't be easy
but feel warmed up a little bit let me
check the global hourly to see how I'm
doing
number nine Oh people can't see it how
do i scroll down now people can kind of
see it so I'm uh right here
I will recognize anyone in first or
anyone uh the top oh I recognize Greece
shook though wow Greece shook 43 okay
let's try and beat Grisha play again
okay speed is important it's meat
mmm let's take with the night whoa
where is maybe just queen Oh queen at
four
wait how do I win f6 screen at 4:28
oh just queen h6 okay
let's take here it's made - it's made
into tax a rook this mates that's gonna
be mates that's nice
I think I accidentally played Bishop e5
there but it wasn't legal because it was
Czech that was nice my knight my tie has
to go back I guess Queen here
insufficient
opposition
hmm could take and then win the bishop
ooh I just promote the pawn B for traps
a queen
I mean in three
hmm ooh take the bishop and wind stuff
wait a minute taketake it's gotta be
taking the bishop
oh the Bishop's hanging and the rook is
hanging oh and his rook is hanging so I
just take okay 28 check and Knight c3
ooh over he had rook to e3 okay it's
checking win the rook no it was May than
one that was bad
okay so I can't mess up anymore
rook b3 probably
take some queen h5
mmm anything better the king runs this
is some sort of like Danish gambit
let's do this
Queen f5
or queen of sudden no probably quite
enough five wait have six mmm let's take
their should I 596
so maybe night before
take e3 and then me five which way are
the pawns going I just push so confusing
or maybe I play Queen ooh this is nice
this is made in two that's beautiful
assume Queenie - there's no checks oh
that's a check take King f7 or rookie it
probably King off sudden check
and check or check
okay where's a mate probably this and
then this and then this okay
so many pawns
that was a weird one
drop the Queen somehow where's the Queen
trap oh I was 92 probably wasn't 92 hmm
38
I tried let's go back and see what I
missed I really don't like this how it's
like messing up the frame let me just
make everything smaller go okay so let's
try this
okay oh yeah this one
so I played Knight c3 not realizing rook
d3 so it's just taking a knight f2 okay
and then this next one
this one I just miss me them one right
it was just check checkmate yeah let's
do it the final one
I was gonna try and play 92 but I was
also debating with 9 f3
but 92 weeny 5 night of 3 queen h5 hmm
so Knight f3 Queen B 4
that's gotta be targeting the Queen
somehow
ninety-two Queenie five
Knight f3 Queen h5 rook h4 Queen g6 and
then II 5
so it doesn't go into that line and now
II five works because the rook is
defended attacking the Queen in the
night okay let's go back okay the
framing looks decent here I think I'll
leave it as is I still want to beat
Greece shook Greece shook is still at
forty three people can see that already
three there okay so let's do one more
slightly addicted Queen takes a 100 or
this okay
so based on the last few I've been
running out of time so I do want to
speed it up
not 9200 as Queen see one with Maidan -
so bad it's a problem when I move too
quickly it was this what is this it's
just making me play on a winning
position okay so ten right one wrong
your key it probably g4
hmmm that's taken Queen g7
which way are the pawns going am i in
check I'm black right so I can take and
then somehow do something
weird position maybe Rick f1 defending
everything
okay
hmm
not seeing it
Brooksie seven trapping the bishop No
takes
I feel slow
I'm just not seeing it
takes off seven
we could take the Queen Queen side
castle maybe that's I don't know not
good
what was that one let's go back let's do
all of them okay this one was just made
into what was the next one
AHA this one rook c7 does not chop the
bishop because Bishop d7 also white is
down a piece so it's probably some
mating net oh maybe it's just night off
five knife f5 threatening 97 meets right
yeah
and the last one
I feel like this is another blind spot
where I'm just missing something obvious
rook takes e5
ah that's just me than to okay feel free
if you're watching on YouTube pause the
video whites and move may than to check
and mates Queen takes off seven okay
let's do one more I really want to beat
Greece shook play again
can eat meat push
creep on
needs an opinion wind probably okay
meets me in three
I'll be Bishop pure take and win the
Queen
Knight g3 and then mates
when the rook
should be some mating net or winning the
night ooh
tricky Ricky three probably rook takes
h3 take e5 and then attack g2 mmm that's
not meat
this looks good this is meat
okay twenty passed pawns must be pushed
Greek gift
take entrap the bishop
maybe a for know this is just meat Queen
here is wins a queen or the rook hmm
let's just take know what's going on
here I can take on e5 so many pins free
Queen push maybe I check and then push
probably h5
what to do take
I'm down the exchange
I feel like I should get to the Kings
somehow maybe I take here and then win
the night okay
probably just bailout for a draw or do I
play this probably this okay
awesome two minutes
take on each for maybe
now what is going on there
okay
[Music]
mmm-maybe g6 okay minute left
I'm just trying to play quickly
no 36 those last three I was under time
pressure because I was too slow earlier
let's look at them
so I played h3 that runs into 9 f6
probably just Bishop e2 yeah
I honestly thought queen f1 was mates
but Bishop g2 defends
so where's mates probably Queen rook h2
Queen g1 somehow wreck h2 King takes h2
having trouble calculating oh queen g1
king h3 queen cf1 Bishop g2 Queen h1
mates
so just to play it out screen g1 queen
f1 queen h1 okay and then the last one
so I got rook takes h7 I assumed that I
should take but where's oh it's just
Queen I fates
queen i faith in them that's me it's
okay that's gonna be hard to beat we
shook let's try one more this will
probably be the last one it's closing
some tabs here okay this will probably
be the last one unless it's not the last
one but we'll see okay playing it
probably Queen takes a Yeats yeah that
great mates
hmm probably just a 5 or do I take
probably take
[Music]
queen bee to only move
past ponds must be pushed
pinin win
skewer and when
it's made in three
hmm
probably this
free night or free Brooke and then three
nights
mmm didn't take my time there let's take
the rook and win the Queen
anta sons
okay
Queen III
Queen f3 there you go
Bishop c2
and trade
and black be three probably or do I take
and then be three probably take no mmm
scared of King f6 so I have two wrong
what to do
and you want to play Brooke a8
probably nights I take Steve or maybe
I really don't know what was this
problem Bishop g5 what was that I was
unfortunate
let's click
yeah I want this video to have a happy
ending but it's not having any happy
ending at least as of now and my
internet is being slow let's go back
here uh is it just rook takes its rook
takes you seven and then queenie one if
King takes and if Queen takes you seven
rook a a check simple stuff I need to
sharpen my tactics okay well I think the
Internet is dead so oh no it's not dead
so which one was this this is where I
wanted to play b3 but King f6 just rook
takes Bishop so I can play b3 right away
yeah and then then probably rotate c4
followed by p2
that one is the same let's go to this
one
wait no I've got that one right
which one was this
John not got this one room correct just
queen take C AIDS what do they play
in Queen d7 I don't even remember what I
played of to go back and re-watch you
know how I could miss that I was
probably playing too quickly or
something okay
oh let's finish with one more this will
be the last one if I do another one
beyond this then something is terribly
wrong it's better to be the last one
let's play again
mmm
tricky checkmate
okay
focus focus
Queen Chuck
Oh Queenie seven maybe oh wait no Queen
that was a terrible
I'm quitting here I was terrible ah what
was that one after rook here
I forgot that rook could just take the
Kohi rook h 8o r okay Jake we need four
okay
that one doesn't count let's do a full
one can i g3 mates
ooh
what
it's 95
oh free bishop
don't overthink things okay I can take
in Queen d4
Chuck Chuck Chuck when the queen
okay
probably take with no not take with
night take with the bishop
probably have to take a bit with the
bishop
Bishop II it's okay
I take and do stuff
to cure
okay
Queeny 425 let's go b2
Simon check
Chuck
hmm
maybe this no oh just this and Bishop e6
okay
ninety-two maybe
chicks check meat
Queen d2
ooh
there's perpetual possibilities
we have to take care
I wouldn't wyneth for I dropped the
Queen
when the queen
mmm that's meat
thirty-six no that looks so easy
maybe this
you know I'll take some men Bishop h6 no
f6 was better I was doing so well
this one's weird maybe King even now
King b8
this one's so confusing whereas a queen
eight maybe queen here then Brooke takes
I really don't see this one can be eight
takes check
maybe King no knocking c6
Queen each to have to break through
ah that wasn't breaking through
does anything break through maybe it's
not a matter of breaking through it's a
matter of just putting blackens lives
long
so it's not it's not a five it's not be
five it's probably c 5 c 5b 5 takes
takes in c 6 yeah alright
okay
what do they get there I was 30
something 38 so I think the session the
high was was 40 which people can't see
now people can see I mean the end it
there I'm getting maliciously attacked
right now by mosquitoes to find some
repellents yeah hope you guys enjoyed
that hopefully people can learn
something from watching I don't know or
at least be entertained feel free to
comment below like what what can you get
as your your high score
can you beat 40 can you beat 30 can you
beat 20 let me know and I will see you
in the next video
take care